I think the best way to learn is
to build an example from scratch.
The sample I showed earlier is from
Google's canonical samples, and
there's a link to them
in the speaker notes.
We're going to build the same
thing from first principles so
that you can see how it's done.
You should be familiar with
the first few steps by now.
You'll create a new
app in Android Studio.
Make it a single zoo application,
don't use any templates.
You'll then add the service libraries
to your build.gradle file and
then once you've done this,
you'll edit your app.manifest
to use these service libraries.
When you've done all of this and
you're ready to go, check this box
to continue to the next video.